elise is in buffalo new york
hi elise how are you hey dave can y'all
hear me
absolutely what's up yeah so
i um first of all huge fan of both you
and can
love the ramsey network and i just want
to i guess you guys can help us
with um like a minor disagreement my
husband and i
are having um so we're both 25
and we're on baby step two right now and
we live
in new york and we're just wondering do
we
need to get a will right now or should
we
wait a year um and get one once we're
done with baby step two because we only
have one asset and it's our car
and both of our names are on it so we're
just wondering do we
yeah need a will in our situation yes
you need a will everyone needs a will
that's an adult
because you otherwise you get tangled up
trying to get his name off the car if he
dies
and if you have a will and states that
it walks right through probate
and it doesn't take two years to sell
the stinking car because the getting the
title straightened out
the will does that the will gives the
court clear instructions on that
and if you um let's say that you didn't
have an asset which is what you're
talking about other than the car
but maybe his mother thought you did
and she decided she wanted to be uh one
of the heirs and there's no will
now you're in an argument with his
mother about an asset that doesn't even
exist
but she is under the illusion that it
does and this is all this kind of crap
is cleared up when there's a will
okay no that makes sense thank you it's
worth the
you know go to my you know you don't
need an expensive detailed
estate plan but it's worth going to
mamabearlegalforms.com spending 100
bucks
and you know you guys have a very clear
thing then
and the other thing that has if both of
you die what happens
two years yeah to your stuff and so
what you get an inexpensive way to do a
will and especially in your situation is
what's called a mirror image will
that says this is what happens if he
dies this is what happens if she dies
and the exact same thing happens if we
both die in both wills
okay and so it would sound like like you
leave everything to him if you die
he leaves everything to you if he dies
and if we both die it all goes to mama
or whoever
what a brother whatever it's going to
okay and you just it's a very clear
thing it's just a cleanliness thing
and
it's not probably going to change your
life except if somebody passes away
but it will lower the hassle factor by a
thousand percent
and that's what you run into ken we've
run into some really
particularly egregious will situations
hers is not lately
a lady called the other day and on the
air here and
after seven years of marriage her
husband had not changed his will
and had not changed the beneficiary on
his life insurance and so
her husband died and they've got two
kids and all the money went to his dad
oh no the good news was his dad
being grandpa says i'm gonna give it all
back to you but they were trying to
figure out how to do that
without the tax problems that that
creates right
and so it's just one of these subjects
that nobody wants to talk about and
everybody has to talk about